first rule of poverty is to wait for
perfect conditions because if you wait
for perfect conditions it assumes that
those are required to be successful when
they are no longer perfect you admit
that you will stop or fail again and so
the best time to start is when it is
hard when things are imperfect because
they will be imperfect again in the
future and if you can succeed when you
are most motivated in the beginning
because it's new and exciting through
the imperfect conditions when those
imperfect conditions happen again you
will already have track record of having
gone through it and so you'll know
you'll be able to continue and so
whether it's weight loss or starting a
business start when it's hard and then
it will get easy don't start when it's
easy